The general Hogan experience.
Because as a comedian, you have to be on social media. I get, I mean,
I don't know way not to be, and it's just like impossible.
Like I am so ridiculously addicted to my phone.
Like the amount of times that I set it down, going like enough with that.
And then I'll just sit there and then five seconds later,
I'm just picking it up. And like,
you know what it is is it's also like I watch when, even when I'm watching TV,
I'll be like, Oh, look at this old movie. I want to, that guy's still alive.
Right. And I said, look, can I die? Why did he die of high? That's you know, 82.
No, it's not bad. You know? And just, let's.
See if someone's talking about me.
I don't do that. I go, let's see what these, uh.
I don't know. Hmm. Social media is bad. I mean, it's good. It's bad. Right.
But the bad part is you can get lost in other people's opinions and want to
defend yourself. And then, you know,
people misrepresent what you said or distort what you said or take it out of
context. And then you're like, Hey, and then you think, well,
how many people are reading that? And thinking the wrong thing about me.
I never respond to it. I don't either. I just flip out.
I would, I do what I call post and ghost. When I make a post,
I make a post and then I put my phone away and I walk out of the room.
I leave my phone.
I thought you were going to say, you write what you want to say,
and then you delete it. And I'll be like, I've been turned over to accidentally.
No, no.
Send I make a post. And then I go away. Right?
Like I don't look at what people are saying about the posts.
I just get the out of there. It's just, it, it never is a good use of time.
There's so many things that I like to do.
And that's one thing that saves me is that I have so many obsessions, right.
Is that I there's so many things. I like to do that, but the phone will get me.
If I'm not, if you know what will get me YouTube,
watching nothing, it'll be an hour. I'll watch a video on how they make watches.
And then I'll watch, uh,
three or four pool matches and then I'll watch a Oh 1970 Chevelle. Oh,
how'd they make that. And then.
But all of those is once you click on one thing,
then they just keep you 40 of the same thing. It's like, they don't,
it's almost like they don't want you to progress is like, um,
like I had like some of, uh, like on my watch,
I think I told this story last time I was on here, like on Netflix,
I watched all of Narcos. Yeah.
And then everything became like behind the scenes of San Quintin and blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. So I've been trying to watch these French movies. Right.
But for some reason it won't because I think I'm here.
They keep giving me like the English speaking ones. It's like,
that's not what I'm trying to do here. I'm trying to watch their. Like,
how do I get out of this kind of keep dragging you back down to.
Well, they find what you're injured. I mean, the algorithm's pretty simple.
I mean, it's not simple, it's complicated,
but it's as a simple formula in terms of like how it applies,
whatever you're interested in,
it's going to show you whatever you're going to spend the most time looking at.
It's going to show you whether it's things you hate, like YouTube or Facebook,
that accentuates things that give you the turn.
It's it turns out it's really just what you're responding to and spending time
on, like did an experiment.
Ari's experiment was he only looked up puppies on YouTube.
That's it just puppies. And then all YouTube was showing them was puppies.
He was trying to tell people, look, this isn't insidious.
It's not like the man's trying to keep you angry. Right.
So you're keeping yourself angry. If you just go and look at puppies all day,
that's all it's going to show you.
I don't know. I feel like if I look at one puppy video,
then they give me a bunch more and it's just like, okay,
maybe I've moved past puppies at this point.
Yeah. But that's up to you. You, yourself,
you have to search for things that aren't puppy related.
I know, but it's just easier just to click on what they're giving out.
More puppy videos is my safe space.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.